je crois que c'est la vidéo je me suis
plus dit comment je vais traiter le
sujet comment gtr tellement c'est
complexe tellement sa part et des fois
un peu opaque comment s'y retrouver et
autant je vous ai déjà fait des vidéos
pour savoir quel iphone choisir quel
smartphone samsung ht où vous avez quand
même dans 400 jours en tout cas une
gamme qui a extrêmement large
mais dans le cas de chiots me je me suis
dit mais par quel bout je vais le proc
tellement il ya de produits tellement
c'est complexe tellement il ya deux
modèles mais bon c'est pas grave j'ai
pris à bras le corps parce qu'il faut
quand même que je vous rendre ce service
à savoir quel smartphone shiomi
acheté en 2020 on va regarder les
différentes gammes les différents
modèles et vous allez voir que bon ça
reste toujours un peu compliqué mais une
fois qu'on s'est vraiment plongé dedans
on arrive à y voir plus clair
d'ailleurs dit que les voix maintenant
aux commentaires est ce que vous avez
déjà acheté un smartphone shiomi est ce
que vous vous êtes pas dit à ce moment
là c'est compliqué je vais m'en sortir
je sais pas quels modèles achetés est-ce
que vous avez un projet d'acheter un
modèle de chiens oui est-ce que vous
étalez sur leur site en se disant quoi
parmi tous les produits lequel acheter
lequel elle fait pour moi je vous dis
tout de suite si vous êtes perdus soyez
rassurés c'est complètement normal
il ya tellement de références au
catalogue que c'est très compliqué de
s'y retrouver
la stratégie de chez l'homme il est très
clair c'est d'inonder le marché que vous
vouliez un produit vraiment dans l'autre
et de ghabbour produit maintenant dans
le très haut de gamme
il ya un modèle shiomi pour tout le
monde il ya deux gros type de produit
chez shiomi le tout premier ce avec les
produits qui marque les produits
vraiment important les projets sur
lesquels il faut compter le deuxième
type de produits ce sont les produits
qui sont un peu là pour inonder le
marché pour un peu noyé l'histoire pour
qu'il y ait tellement de produits xiaomi
et bien qu'on les voit un peu partout et
que quand on pense à acheter un
smartphone on pense pas à dire tiens
quel mac tellement que je vais acheter
mais quel produit chez chuo mise de
prendre on va donc fonctionné plutôt par
gamme plutôt que par modèle fait cette
vidéo on est au mois de mai 2020 on sait
les produits qui sont sortis jusqu'au
mois de mai 2020 en tout cas jusqu'à
date à laquelle je tourne par contre on
a absolument aucune visibilité sur ce
qui va arriver sur le reste de l'année
et connaîtront shiomi à mon avis il va y
avoir pléthore de nouveaux modèles chez
xiaomi vous avez tout d'abord la gagne
qui est le plus haut de gamme mais vous
avez également la gamme minis à qui
correspond à l'endroit idoine
vous avez la gamme mx vous vous
retrouvez l'innovation par le design
vous avez mis max mais vous avez
également raid me qui va se décliner sur
les raids minott et sur les autres
modèles qui vont être un peu plus
standard l'airé demi avec des numéros
mais c'est pas tout puisque vous avez
également pour qu phone et dans chacune
de ces catégories
vous avez bien souvent beaucoup de
produits hormis pour wimax
hormis pour coco phone est là est-ce que
c'est pas un peu le bazar il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de gars et dans toutes
ses gammes ya aussi beaucoup trop de
produits dans la gamme me vous allez
avoir le modèle qu'on va appeler le
modèle normal le modèle standard c'est à
dire mis 9 me disent bon la numérotation
classique
ensuite on a le modèle professionnel le
modèle pro sera un modèle surboosté ans
et notamment la vue cette année avec le
met dix pros en termes de photos qui est
vraiment bien meilleure puisqu'il a
exactement les mêmes performances qu'un
modèle normal vous avez pas contre
ensuite le modem light où on garde l'adn
de la gamme mais par contre on va avoir
des performances ils seront bien moins
bonne
ensuite l'année dernière on a eu le
minefe t c'est le grand écran cent en
poche on a eu ensuite le mil neuf t3 qui
aller beaucoup plus loin en terme de
performance avec un processeur beaucoup
plus puissants et on en suit le modèle
spécial édition le est ce qui est juste
là pour nous embêter et complexifier la
gamme mais ça ne s'arrête pas là puisque
vous avez également le minott avec le
minot disque est sorti fin 2010 là on
n'est que sur la gamme mis le plus haut
de gamme et voyez déjà la complexité du
truc alors vous avez des modèles qui
sont les modèles incontournables les
modèles les plus importants qu'il faut
vraiment prendre en considération et ya
des modèles qui servent un peu à rien on
peut venir oublier détails ça vous
explique vous allez voir c'est au final
pas si compliqué que ça on va tout de
suite commencer par retirer les modèles
qui pour moins de services globale m'en
a pas grand chose pour moi ça va être le
min 10 pourquoi parce que le minot de 10
il est arrivé fin d'année 2010 9
c'est un peu un produit intermédiaire
entre le mit 9 et le me disent c'était
le premier smartphone avec cinq capteurs
photo il était là pour montrer un peu
l'avancé technologique de shiomi mais
aujourd'hui globalement il a vraiment
été dépassées par d'autres modèles
donc ce modèle là il est vraiment venue
surtout pour une notion timing on a
notre modèle qu'on peut venir supprimer
tout de suite c'est le s pour moi le
seul c'est pareil il sert globalement
pas grand chose c'est un modèle oublié
on a un processeur milieu de gamme
on est un peu dans le combo classique de
l'année dernier
au niveau de la faute aux capteurs 48
mégapixels plus un ultra grand-angle
plus un téléobjectif vous avez un design
un peu standard avec une eau que je
goûte d'eau mais celui là c'est pareil
on va l'oublier
notre modèle à oublier c'est le modèle
light il est là pour constituer la gamme
mais vous trouverez des choses bien plus
intéressantes qui sortiront au cours de
l'année donc le modèle lie pour moi
c'est pareil je vais le supprimer il
nous reste ensuite le modèle normal le
modèle pro le mode lte et lte et pro vu
que là je vous parle des modèles de
l'année dernière notamment du neuf des
dix neuf des pros j'ai tout de suite
venir supprimer le 9 pts et pourquoi
parce que même s'il est pas mal le neuf
et pro a quand même baissé en prie vous
avez exactement la même chose en terme
de photos sauf que là vous avez un
dragon 855 quelque chose de plus
puissant
donc c'est pareil pour moi le modalités
je le lirai nous reste au niveau de la
gaming trois modèles le modèle normal
le modèle professionnel et le thé pro de
l'année dernière je vous renvoie bien
évidemment à mes vidéos sur le midi et
lui disent pro les différences que vous
allez avoir c'est que le midi ce procès
avec le modèle le plus abouti avec la
meilleure expérience multimédia la
meilleure expérience de gaming
smartphone extrêmement performant qui
est en tête du classement à l'heure
actuelle vous allez avoir une superbe
expérience en termes de photos et une
très belle montée en gamme pour chier au
mythe qui à sa sortie coûte 999 euros
dont 200 euros de moins vous allez
perdre en terme de photo le capteur
principal il ya un très bien c'est le
même mais le reste ce sera quand même un
peu moins bon donc c'est toujours une
question de budget le modèle t par
contre de l'année dernière je sais pas
si on aura cette année à l'heure à
laquelle je tourne cette vidéo mais le
modèle t est intéressant pourquoi parce
que vous avez un grand écran cent en
poche avec une caméra pop up
donc si vous voulez un smartphone
suffisamment performant avec un dragon
et bien ce modèle là plus aussi être
vraiment fait pour vous la gamme mais y
as tout de suite beaucoup plus simple
c'est la gamme android one vous aimez
xiaomi vous aimez la marque vous voulez
un smartphone milieu de gamme vous
voulez pas y mettre trop d'argent mais
par contre vous n'aimez pas leurs
surcouches new wave vous voulez une
expérience android pure sans fioritures
sans surcouche sans rien et c'est là que
la gamme mis à et fait pour vous puisque
c'est exactement ça va donc retrouver un
smartphone milieu de gamme avec cette
expérience android pur l'année dernière
il ya eu le mia trois types de caméras
le premier capteur 148 mégapixels
deuxième c'est un ultra grand temps les
troisièmes il sera là pour le mode
portrait pour les faits évoqués bon on
est sur un grand standard ça fonctionne
et ensuite on a mis mix et mimiques
c'est extrêmement simple c'est tout
simplement le
design le dernier mimiques sortie c'est
le mime x3 avec son slider avec un dos
en céramique on est vraiment dans tout
autre chose on est vraiment quelque
chose un peu plus ni chez des personnes
qui cherchent un produit très
particulier avec en tout cas au moment
où il est sorti une des toutes dernières
technologies un grand écran sans
encoches un slider alors pour l'instant
il ne devrait pas y avoir de minix 4 le
boss de chez o'neal et john a dit pour
l'instant il n'y aura pas d'autres
produits mix mais la gamme n'est pas
terminée la gamme des panthères et donc
il se pourrait qu'à l'avenir on ne sait
pas quand il y ait d'autres produits
mimix mais ce qui est sûr c'est que pour
l'instant c'est absolument pas une
priorité de la marque me max comme son
nom l'indiqué c'est plutôt l'idée de
grand format mais ça c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment amené à disparaître je
suis pas sûr qu'ils d'autres modèles
donc en tout cas en 2020 le même axe on
peut le supprimer
on se retrouve ensuite sur la question
du poteau von arx pourquoi fans c'est
vachement intéressant parce que quand le
pot coop en f1 étaient présentés en
france il ya un an et demi
eh bien on nous présentait un smartphone
extrêmement puissant qui était vraiment
eu l'idée du flagship killer il y à un
autre modèle poko phone qui est
présentée mais qui pour l'instant
n'arriverait pas en france donc pour
l'instant poko phone alors à la question
cette vidéo et bien on peut également
oublié mais c'est pas dit que peut-être
dans le courant de l'année voire 2021 on
voit arriver un beau copenhague 2 mais
pour l'instant rien n'est sûr il nous
reste ensuite rémy qui se décompose en
deux parties
rewmi note et puis rémy classique alors
la reine linotte vous êtes comme ça et
vous nagez pas tant pour les produits
parce qu'on les comprend extrêmement
facilement mais c'est pour le nom des
produits que dernier sortie en date
s'appelle leurs ennemis note 9 s s on
sait pas pourquoi pensez pas pourquoi on
remonte à l'année dernière l'année
dernière sortie deux produits le raid
min 8 et qui était le renmin de suite
plus d'entrée de gamme et ensuite leur
ennemi ne suis trop pro comprend
professionnels plus de galles plus haut
on comprend mais il n'y a pas de rémy
notre suite de sortie en tout cas ici en
france on remonte à l'année d'avant est
sorti leurs ennemis note 7 ya pas eu de
rémy note 7 pro pas de renmin d'accepter
pas de raid min 7 s et on voit que
d'année en année et bien on a les noms
qui changent alors ils correspondent
forcément quelque chose mais pour le
consommateur
on comprend absolument rien vous voyez
un raid min 9 s vous dites ok donc si je
reviens de l'alimentation 8 aces qui est
ce à quoi ça correspond et bien je vous
le dis tout de suite on oublie
la dénomination des produits la seule
chose qu'on peut retenir ses propos pour
le renmin de tuiles pro on comprend que
c'est le modèle le plus haut de gamme
qu'il faudra plus que le renmin de suite
et mais au-delà de ça t'es chez moi
pourquoi donc sans la gamme rémy note on
va se concentrer sur deux types de
produits le produit qu'on va appeler le
produit normal le produit courant le
produit commun et le produit pro ou la
dénomination est très très clairs la
gamme renmin note
elle est vraiment là pour vous apporter
le meilleur rapport qualité prix le
meilleur compromis avec une très grosse
autonomie c'est pas là vous allez avoir
le meilleur écran c'est pas là vous
allez faire les meilleures photos
c'est pas là vous allez voir le
smartphone le plus performant néanmoins
pour faire tourner beaucoup de jeu du
blé store pour faire des photos
souvenirs profiter d'une expérience
multimédia correct avec une bonne
autonomie
eh bien vous aurez un excellent rapport
qualité prix avec un modèle frau qui va
se situer aux alentours des 249 euros au
moment de sa sortie et sur le modèle un
peu plus standard aux alentours de 170
euros 160 euros
donc voyez on est vraiment sur des
produits qui sont pas chers mais qui
sont extrêmement honnête et d'ailleurs
j'ai souvent recommandé leur ennemi note
7 comme étant pour moi un smartphone de
référence dans cette gamme de prix
rémy c'est beaucoup plus simple vous
avoir une numérotation et vous allez
avoir la lettre a derrière on est
vraiment sur les produits qui sont plus
d'entrée de gamme avec le nom un petit
peu normal renmin 8h30 7h30 6 et vous
allez avoir également la numérotation
reno 1,8 à rémy 6 a réuni 7 à on a aussi
un raid meego mais celui là on le prend
on oublie donc rémy avec sa numérotation
un peu standard sans toi que
numérotation et le a notamment leurs
ennemis 8 ha
on est vraiment sur un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme pour commencer à
arriver xiaomi par contre on n'aura pas
du tout en écran full hd on aura un
écran hd
on n'aura pas des caméras dingue qu'on
n'aura pas un processeur très puissant
arrière mais néanmoins vous aurez une
bonne autonomie vous aurez un smartphone
de chez omid qui fera bien l'affairé qui
vous permettra d'aller chez xiaoming un
tarif tout de suite beaucoup plus doux à
côté de ça chez omi a présenté le mit
mix alpha qui est un concept phone qui
vous montrent ce que xiaomi est capable
de faire mais qui est pas un smartphone
qui est fait pour être vendues à
monsieur et madame tout le monde
il ya également le smartphone pliable de
chez un ami qui a été montré il ya un
peu plus d'un an mais qui n'est pas du
tout à l'ordre du jour il ya absolument
aucunes infos qui circulent sur
l'arrivée potentielle d'un smartphone
plus a fléchi au mit alors soyez sûr que
ça finira bien par arriver dans les
années à venir lorsque le pliable à sera
plus démocratisé à ce moment là je suis
en me serais là pour vous présenter
leurs solutions dont vous voyez on
partait sur quelque chose de très
complexe et au final on a élagué et ça
va tout de suite beaucoup mieux alors on
va se faire un petit résumé la gamme me
c'est vraiment ce que vous avez de plus
haut de gamme chéchia ou si vous avez le
budget et si vous voulez vraiment vous
faire plaisir avec ce que je suis au
mime et rizeries mieux vous allez sur le
modèle professionnel vous le regretterez
pas si tout de suite ça tire un petit
peu mais vous voulez quand même la
superbe expérience multimédia le modèle
standard ira très bien notamment le midi
ce modèle tu es pro 100 modèles de
l'année dernière 109 pourquoi pas si
vous voulez un grand écran avec la
caméra pop up ça fera la sphère avoir
effectivement dans cette gamme là ce
qu'on va nous sortir shiomi en 2020 et
les connaissons on n'est pas au bout de
nos surprises
millas et pour android douanes on
pourrait voir arriver un millier à 4 des
recours en août si le calendrier pas
trop modifier à cause du coronavirus
vous ai montré le mx3 mais c'est un
smartphone à oublier puisque en termes
de performances il va être dépassé
mais en tout cas c'est plus pour moi un
smartphone à acheter si vous voulez un
smartphone avec un prix beaucoup plus
doux vous diriger vers la gamme note
renmin note modèles propres à un peu
plus cher selon le modèle normal ira
très bien
si vous avez les moyens si les trouver
un modèle pro un peu moins cher
d'ailleurs je vous ai mis des liens en
bas dans la description et si vraiment
vous voulez arriver chez suis remis avec
un prix tout doux tout doux tout doux
eh bien vous avez l'air et demi
notamment leurs ennemis huit et demi
huit à sans compter bien évidemment sur
ce que schumi va nous pondre cette année
quand vous voyez il ya un smartphone de
chiots me pour tout le monde avoue
trouver le vote d'ailleurs dit moi vous
en commentaire si vous avez un
smartphone de chez tommy quel modèle
vous avez acheté et pour quelles raisons
et si vous en êtes satisfait oui ou non
je pense que chacun pourrait trouver un
petit peu son bonheur là dedans alors ça
veut pas dire que les modèles que j'ai
retiré ne sont pas des bons modèles mais
un moment et vu la complexité de la
gamme il faut quand même dire un petit
peu tranchée à débroussailleuse parce
que sinon on ne s'en sortira absolument
pas et je vous dis une fois de plus je
tourne cette vidéo on est au moins de
mai 2020 je connais shiomi je sais que
les annonces vont continuer à arriver et
je pense qu'à la fin de l'année
ça va encore se complexifier garder
vraiment cette vision des choses est ce
que c'est un modèle qui va s'inscrire
dans le temps est ce que c'est un modèle
qui est là pour occuper le terrain et ça
vous aidera à faire votre choix puis
bien évidemment au bout du bout du bout
ce qui compte c'est l'argent que vous
allez mettre dedans donc essayer de
trouver le meilleur rapport qualité prix
par rapport à votre budget et si ça vous
intéresse déjà mis des liens bien
évidemment en bas dans la description
sur ce je vous embrasse moi beaucoup
d'amour et se donnent rendez vous dès
demain pour continuer à parler de teck
allée des câlins bisous bisous
[Musique]
bayon
m
moi
[Musique]